so and today nat wolff and i are just
going to go to the woods and do a
question Tuesday that sounded weird
joking good morning Hank it's Tuesday
it's question Tuesday that we answer
real questions from real nerdfighters
I'm here with NAT Wolff who's playing
Isaac in the movie and I'm going to ask
him some questions I like you that you
guys submitted from Twitter yet right
another button it's right in there
alright Matt your first question is
shailene woodley a good kisser a bad was
a question meant for me
awkward pan uh-oh yeah I wouldn't know I
sadly Isaac doesn't get to kiss hazel
yeah have you guys read the book yeah
but hasn't happened what part of the
book are you most excited to see in the
movie I'm excited to see I think I did
the trophy scene I think that went well
I'm excited to see all the scenes that
don't have Isaac in them hmm
not as much for me who's the funniest
person on the Fault in Our Stars Sam two
three it's me it definitely made me its
minute I know I'm okay it's John your
second your second but it's a distant
second how true to the book is the movie
very true I think it's because people
you trying to get me out of this camera
angle John so true the little kids the
movie that I think people are so in love
this book and it's so realistic already
we there's barely anything that anybody
had to change but I can't help but
notice that you don't have blonde hair
ah
except for my blonde hair as the author
of the book I just want to say that that
stuff doesn't matter to me at all um
maybe I'll make a tumblr post about why
it doesn't matter to me and link to it
in the video info below yeah so the guys
for all the tweets about me not being
blonde I'm sorry Todd it's not his fault
he was born that way neither my parents
have blonde hair I just couldn't control
it they were you know blame them if you
could only watch one more movie in your
life net what would it be uh it would
probably be taxi driver I think taxi
driver is fun out there movie of all
time
for me it would definitely be the Fault
in Our Stars I meant the fall to us yeah
what's it been like hanging out with
actual teen cancer survivors it was it
was overwhelming I went to a hospital
and I talked to them and you know you
start off asking them questions about
their disease and how they cope with it
and about five minutes in year talking
about movies and TV shows music just
like with anybody else right and you
realize they're just normal kids or just
going through a really lame situation
have you seen me cry on set at all yeah
I have John cries it at a good meal now
this is your second movie with Josh
Boone yes director what do you think of
that
screw him man yeah it's kind of lame
Josh Boone is like one of my best
friends in the world honestly hopefully
I'll be working with him for you know
the rest of my career
yeah that's how I feel about NAT I want
to work with in the lab but not with
John for those not on movies you know
just like just like work on little
project we could build a house together
what's it like playing a blind person
when I'm doing the scenes Bly I can't
say anything I put stuff over my glasses
or I'm wearing these contacts and make
it so I can't say anything and it's
almost freeing because you become really
you lose all self-consciousness
physically I watched a lot of videos
online of blind people I met with this
guy named Ethan and I watched Scent of a
Woman I got those speeches memorized you
know you got the Al Pacino blinds guys
like I'm in the dog Charlie I'm in the
dog so I'm trying to work that into the
movie so no Ange I got fired over to
this place
give me Samantha oh hey Doug what're you
talking about
no um I'm having a good time today
here's my John be quiet cuz we got in
trouble do you have a favorite book I
mean my favorite book of all time is
catching a ride and also because like
hazel I think I read it at a really
important time in my life when a book
and mean that much to you catching their
eyes also my probably my favorite book
that must be why is that really so yeah
really a favorable yeah you made I'll
send you my videos I made about it
favorite Beatle Oh favorite color blue
now C minor minor John and green
honestly John is it now as I get older
becomes more my favorite find yourself
do you find yourself owner under green
at all as a color at all damn it
one two three hey I'll see you on Friday
that's a long time where's the little
West Lane but a little better than that
1 2 3
Hank 1 2 3 Hank I'll see you on Friday
that was good yeah finally